good evening for those of us here
tonight that are 70 years old or younger
Jack Cardiff was shooting film before we
were born
and he's still shooting starting in
front of the camera as a child actor at
the age of four Jack Cardiff born in
Yarmouth England to vaudevillian parents
moved his professional career behind the
camera a decade later he hasn't budged
from that spot since in the years that
followed he learned his craft as
thoroughly and completely as anyone can
and achieved an incomparable
international reputation for his mastery
of color and light some have said that
he may have given birth to Technicolor
for three generations Jack brought
something extraordinary into our lives
an indelible vision of cinematic
splinter this is the first time an
honorary Oscar has been given to a
cinematographer
ladies and gentlemen it is my special
privilege to present to you mr. Jack
Carter
where's the L stick well for God's sake
can't take him anywhere this this has to
be a dream
I often dream I'm working on a movie but
this one tonight is a biggie
I mean God all these filmmakers and
black tie that's extra God would be over
budget it's a nightmare
and this wonderful Oscar it's not real
it's a special effects it's amazing
isn't it oh all right
I'm not dreaming but it's mighty close
an honor like this for a whole lifetime
span is an awesome air about it and
embracing all the years I've worked 70
more than 70 in fact thinking of all
those millions of difficult setups and
millions of takes and retakes but
tonight it's also worthwhile
I give my heartfelt thanks to the
Academy for this great ultimate honor
and thank you all so much for being on
the set thank you
the Oscars will return in a California
moment with samuel l.jackson Sarah
Jessica Parker and the presentation of
some more coveted Oscars don't go away